finally avengers phase two is complete
you know if you think about it you got
batman lois lane hawkeye
katniss everdeen
and face from
the successful movie the a-team
american hustle this film is badass like
if you saw this film walking down the
street and you saw that ass you'd be
like damn
that ass is bad and then you're gonna
look to your buddy and go dang i wanna
bang that ass
then your buddy's gonna be like whoa
dude anal sex is dangerous for you and
then you're gonna be like i don't care i
wanna try it and then you're gonna be
like dude it's a [ __ ] movie you
cannot bang a movie's ass a movie does
not have an ass
why are we even having this conversation
that's a true story between me and
my friend jerry it's exciting it's
character driven it's
funny it's incredibly clever every cast
member in this film
is astonishing best ensemble of the year
the number one thing that crosses my
mind
whenever i think about it that of course
being christian [ __ ]
bale i want you off the [ __ ]
certainly prick and i'm pretty sure he's
jewish
he is the coolest fattest jew i have
ever seen in a movie the key to his
performance is his sincerity
and his confidence he's just so layered
in this movie
absolutely deserves an oscar nomination
for his performance and yes
if you're a fan of the show you know
what's coming next
i'm totally gonna suck fat ass christian
bales dick
holy [ __ ] amy adams every time she came
on screen
i came in my pants this is the hottest
the sexiest amy adams has ever been
except for the movie doubt she played a
nun in that movie that's that's what
makes the joke funny her role requires
her to be
likable manipulative but seductive
and she does such a good job at it she
plays christian bale's mistress
and i've had the fortunate opportunity
to meet plenty of women who are dating
married men apparently these women
wouldn't suck a single guy's dick but
they'll suck a merry guy's penis
you [ __ ] [ __ ] broke my heart
anyway yeah amy adams very authentic
performance
bradley cooper he has a perm i can make
a pubic hair joke here but i'm not going
to bradley cooper is the cop who becomes
drunk with power imagine what his pubes
look like i had to say it i had to say
it i've never seen cooper in a roll like
this
maybe you accept a little bit of wedding
crashers in there i mean
in terms of you know being a douche with
power status but cooper
super authentic very subtle performance
and it's awesome to see him and bale on
the same screen together
his performance is certainly
limitless if you were to ask me is
bradley cooper's performance awesome in
this movie
i'd say yes man he was in yes man that
film with jim carrey you know what i'm
talking about no one [ __ ] watched
that film but me
and my best friend jerry jennifer
lawrence she is one of the best
actresses working today
she gave me a winter's bo oh wait no i
made that joke on another episode so i
wanna
repeat myself once again brings another
character to life a character i was
questionable about fully believing
because this is like
a role you would see to like a much
older person she plays bale's wife and
she
is an annoying b-i-t-c-h [ __ ]
there were times where i literally hated
her not because her performance sucked
just because it was so
good that i actually ended up hating
this person she really knows how to play
a stupid person
there's one scene where everyone's
talking about you know where amy adams
and chen for
lawrence and you know they have a little
smooch short-lived but awesome they kiss
i came moving on and jeremy renner he
plays the mayor of atlanta who really
cares the big [ __ ] about his people
he rocks an ace ventura style haircut
his performance wasn't like outlandish
it's a very subtle very real performance
it's as good as
his performance in hansel and gretel
witch hunters i'm gonna give away
spoiler here
but this story is actually hawkeye's
origin story yeah
you know it honestly it doesn't make any
[ __ ] sense
i didn't see the connection at all but
my buddy you know he knows a lot about
comic books and he
he read the american hustle comic book i
haven't read it yet but he said he's
gonna buy it for me in a year
last performer i gotta mention louis ck
he plays bradley cooper's boss without a
doubt he's one of my all-time favorite
comedians his stand-up makes me piss my
pants every time
literally it is embarrassing i have done
this in front of many women
one of them liked it sure there's an
aura of you know hammer to his
performance but for the most part it's a
very sincere very dramatic performance
and have you seen his stand up hilarious
it is
hilarious
[ __ ] witty comedy man always gets me
the direct team by [ __ ] abusive to
his cast and crew director
david o russell i don't care how [ __ ]
insane this guy can be to people on set
he's a damn good director
and if people get in the [ __ ] way of
that they deserve to be pushed to the
ground so back off george clooney i
didn't mean that george clooney i'm
sorry this guy's on a roll he did the
fighter
silver linings playbook and now this
holy
he captured the tone and vibe of the 70s
it was like living in the 70s
actually how the [ __ ] would i know that
because i wasn't in the 70s so you know
like a lot of douchebags like me say
that but i
for all i know there's nothing like what
the 70s felt like his direction feels
scorsese inspired but the main thing i
got from his direction is just how well
he understands his characters how well
he can work with actors
even if sometimes he treats them like
this i'm being a [ __ ] collaborator i
was trying to help you figure out here
get [ __ ] pictures hey [ __ ] i'm not
here to be [ __ ] yelled at i worked on
this [ __ ] thing
for three [ __ ] years knocked out some
[ __ ] [ __ ]
yell at me in front of the [ __ ] crew
when i'm trying to [ __ ] help you
[ __ ]
figure it out yourself [ __ ] yourself
you gotta admit you would have wanted to
be there on that day so you can tell
everybody you [ __ ] saw that the
writing is fantastic you know what i
loved about this film was
except you know there's a lot of things
i loved about it obviously which i have
a feeling audiences might not like is
that this film
is not so much about the hustle it's
about the american people
in this film not about the united states
of america you know what i'm talking
about and how these events and
situations affect their lives
it's just a strongly written character
film but don't get me wrong the hustle
is still pretty [ __ ] cool i'm a
hustler man i'm a hustler
almost did it this one has a great
ending twist that i did not see
coming like when bruce willis died at
the end of the whole nine yards this is
just one of those movies that has it all
remember the whole 10 yards what a piece
of [ __ ]
great directing great writing great
acting great production design
this film is the [ __ ]
poop joke can go here let me get
straight to the point here all in all i
gotta say american hustle got it super
duper
right
all right guys let's check out my review
for american hustle why don't you go
ahead scroll that comment box below
and tell me who do you prefer fat
christian male
or ridiculously skinny christian male
and if you want to see more episodes of
my [ __ ]
bam right here more movie reviews
because you need to hear my opinion and
last but not least if you want to get
updated every time one of my reviews is
out go ahead and click on this button on
my dick to subscribe
that's right the dick or as i like to
call it
christian bale and the bradley cooper
go and click on this button by my dick
to subscribe
that's right the dick
or as i call it the hustle
and this dog
who am i going with